[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH DILLON: Hello, everyone.
I'm Josh Dillon, and I'm a lead
on the TensorFlow probability
team.
And today, I'm going to talk
to you about probability stuff
and how it relates
to TensorFlow stuff.
So let's find out
what that means.
OK, so these days,
machine learning
often means specifying
deep model architectures
and then fitting
them under some loss.
And happily, Keras makes
specifying model architecture
relatively easy.
But what about the loss?
Choosing the right
loss is tough.
Improving one-- even
a reasonable one--
can be even tougher.
And once you fit your model,
how do you know it's good?
Does accuracy tell
the full picture?
Why not use mean, entropy, mode?
Wouldn't it be great
if there existed
some mathematical framework,
which unified these ideas?
Better still,
wouldn't it be nice
if it was plug and play with
Keras and the rest of TF?
This would make comparing models
easier by simply maximizing
likelihood and having
readily available
evaluative statistics.
We can rapidly prototype
different generating
assumptions and quickly
reject the bad ones.
In short, wouldn't it be
great if we could do this--
just say I want to
maximize the log likelihood
and then summarize
what I learned easily
and in a unified way?
So let's play with that idea.
Here, we have a data
set-- these blue dots.
And our task--
our pretend task--
is to predict the y-coordinate
from the x-coordinate.
And the way you might do this
is specify some deep model.
And of course, you might
choose the mean squared error
as your loss function.
OK.
But our wish here is to
think probabilistically.
And so that means maximizing
the log likelihood,
as indicated here with
this lambda function--
the negative random
variable log_prob under y.
And what we want,
in addition to that,
is to get back a
distribution-- a thing
that has attached
to it statistics
that we can use to evaluate
what we just learned.
If only such a
thing were possible.
Of course, it is, and
you can do this now.
Using TensorFlow probability
distribution layers,
you can specify the model
as part of your deep net.
And the loss now
is actually part
of the model, sort of
the way it used to be--
the way it's meant to be.
And so let's unpack
what's happening here.
So we have two dense layers.
That's sort of
business as usual.
The second one
outputs one float,
and that one float
is parameterizing
a normal distributions mean.
And that's being done through
this distribution lambda layer.
In so being, we're
able to find this line.
That looks great.
And the best part is,
once we instantiate
this model with test points,
we have back a distribution
instance--
for which you get not
just the mean, which
is what you'd get
today, but also--
get not just the mean, which is
what you'd get today, but also
entropy variance, standard
deviation, all of these things.
And you can even compare between
this and other distributions,
as we'll see later.
But if we look at
this data, something's
still a little
fishy here, right?
Notice that as the magnitude of
x increases, the variance of y
also seems to increase.
So that means that maybe our
model's a little suspicious.
So since we're in this
probabilistic framework
and we're no longer
doing loss hacking--
we're actually
building a model--
what can we do to fix this?
Answer-- learn the variance too.
It's actually pretty obvious.
If we're fitting a
normal, why on earth
do we think that the
variance would just be 1?
And by the way,
that's what you're
doing when you use
mean squared error.
And so now, to achieve
this, all I had to do
is make my previous
layer output two floats.
I pass one in as the
mean to the normal, one
in as the standard
deviation of the normal.
And presto chango, now I've
learned the standard deviation
from the data itself.
That's what the green lines are.
So this is really cool, because
now, if you're a statistician,
you would say, hey, I'm able
to handle heteroscedasticity.
If you want a $10
word, you can call
this aleatoric uncertainty.
And what this really
means is that you're
learning known unknowns.
It means that the data
itself had variance,
and you learned it.
And it cost you
basically nothing
to do but a few keystrokes.
And furthermore, the way in
which you saw how to do this
was self-evident
from the very fact
that you were using a
normal distribution which
had this curious constant
just sitting there.
So this is good.
But, hm, I don't know.
Is there enough data for
which we can reliably
claim that this red line
is actually the mean,
and these green
lines are actually
the standard deviation?
How would we know if
we have enough data?
Is there anything
else we can do?
Of course, there is.
Why learn just a
single set of weights?
A Keras dense slayer has two
components-- a kernel matrix
and a bias vector.
What makes you think that
those point estimates are
the best, especially given that
your data set itself is random
and possibly inadequate to
meaningfully and reliably learn
those point estimates?
Instead, if you use a
TensorFlow probability
dense variational layer, you can
actually learn a distribution
overweight.
This is the same as
learning an ensemble that's
infinitely large.
But luckily, it
doesn't take infinitely
long to train this ensemble.
In fact, it takes just
a little bit longer
than what it took to train
on the previous slides.
And as you can see
here, all I had to do
is replace Keras.dense with
TFP.dense variational layer,
and in so doing,
achieve this kind
of Bayesian weight uncertainty.
The $10 word here is
epistemic uncertainty.
But again, I like to think
of it as unknown unknowns.
I'm not sure what my
data is not telling me,
so I'm going to be careful
in the bookkeeping I
make when tracking the
weights that I learn.
As a consequence,
of course, this
means that any model you make,
any instantiation of this model
is now actually a random
variable because the weight's
a random variable.
And that's why you see
here all of the lines.
There are many lines.
We have an ensemble of them.
But if you were to average
those and take the sample
standard deviation,
say, then that
would give you an estimate
of credible intervals
over your prediction.
So now you can go
to your customer
and say, look, here's
what I think would happen,
and here's how much
you should trust me.
So this is great, right?
But we seem to have lost
the heteroscedastic part.
Notice that the blue
dots are still more
dispersed on the
right-hand side.
So can we do both?
Of course, we can.
It's all modular.
I just have my dense operational
layer output 2 floats, instead
of one, like we did before.
Feed that into my output layer,
which is a normal distribution.
And presto chango, I'm
learning both known and unknown
unknowns, and all it cost
me was a few keystrokes.
And so what you see here now
is an ensemble of standard
deviations associated with
the known unknown parts--
the variance present or
observable in the y-axis--
as well as a number
or an ensemble
of these mean regressions.
OK, that's cool.
So I like where this is going.
But I have to ask, what makes
you think a line is even
the right thing to fit here?
Is there another distribution
we could choose, a richer
distribution, that
would actually find
the right form of the data?
And of course,
the answer is yes.
It's a Gaussian process.
By tossing in this
fancy distribution,
it turns out that the
data wasn't linear at all.
No wonder we had such
a hard time fitting it.
It was sinusoidal, and the
Gaussian process can see this.
How can the Gaussian
process see this?
Because it treats the loss
itself as a random variable.
Now, how could you do that,
if you're just specifying mean
squared error as your loss?
You can't.
It has to be part of your
model, and that's the power
of probabilistic modeling.
When you bake in these
ideas into one model,
you get to move things
around fluidly between weight
uncertainty and
variance in the data,
and even uncertainty in the loss
function you're fitting itself.
And so the question is, how
can this all be so easy?
How did it all fit together?
It's TensorFlow Probability.
So TensorFlow Probability
is a collection
of tools designed to make
probabilistic reasoning
in TensorFlow easier.
It is not going to
make your job easy.
It's just going to give
you the tools you need
to express the ideas you have.
You still have to have domain
knowledge and expertise.
But you can encode that
domain knowledge and expertise
in a probabilistic
formalism, and TFP
has the tools to do that.
Statisticians and
data scientists
will be able to write and
launch the same model.
Gone are the days of hacking
your model in R and importing
it over to a faster language,
like C++, or even TensorFlow.
You can do it all in
the same framework.
ML researchers and
practitioners will
be able to make predictions
with uncertainty.
If you predict the
light is green,
you'd better be pretty
confident that you should go.
You can do that with
probabilistic modeling
and TensorFlow Probability.
So we saw one small part of TFP.
Broadly speaking, the tools
are broken in two components--
those tools useful for
building models and those tools
useful for doing
inference on those models.
On the model building side,
you saw the normal distribution
and the variation of Gaussian
process distribution.
A distribution is just is a
collection of simple summary
statistics, exactly like it
is in every other library.
There's a few differences.
R distribution
support, this concept
of batch shape, which
automatically takes advantage
of vector processing hardware.
But for the most
part, they should be
pretty natural and easy to use.
We also have something
called bijecters,
which is a library for
transforming random variables.
In the simplest
case, this can be
like taking the x of the normal,
and now you have a lognormal.
In more complicated
cases, it can
involve transforming a random
variable with a neural network.
This includes things like
mask autoregressive flows,
if you've heard
about it, real MVPs,
and other sophisticated
probabilistic models.
You saw layers.
We also have some losses that
help you build Monte Carlo
approximations to otherwise
intractable calculations.
Edward2 is our probabilistic
programming language
that helps you combine different
random variables as one.
On the inference side,
no Bayesian library
would be complete without
Markov chain Monte Carlo
tools, within which we have
several transition kernels.
One of them is called
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo,
which naturally takes
advantage of TensorFlow's
automatic differentiation
capability.
We also have tools
for performing
variational inference--
again, taking
advantage of TF's automatic
differentiation and optimizer
toolbox.
And of course, we have
our own optimizers
that often come up in
probabilistic modeling
problems, such as Nelder-Mead,
BFGS, things like that.
The point is, this toolbox
has maybe not everything,
but certainly, it
has most of what
you might need to do fancier
modeling to actually get
more out of your
machine learning model.
And it doesn't have to be hard.
You saw the Keras
examples were just
a sequence of one line changes.
So of course,
TensorFlow probability
is used widely around Alphabet.
DeepMind uses it extensively.
Google Brain uses it.
Google accelerated sciences,
product areas-- infrastructure
areas even use it for
planning purposes.
But it's also used
outside of Google.
So Baker Hughes GE is one of
our early adopters of TensorFlow
probability, and
they use it to build
models to detect anomalies.
Anomaly detection is a very
hard problem because, hopefully,
your data set never
has the anomaly
you're trying to detect.
For example, anyone
who flew out here
would be happy to know
that Baker Hughes GE uses
its anomaly detection to predict
the lifespan of jet engines.
And if we had a data set that
had a failing jet engine,
that would be a tragedy.
And so using math, we can
get around this by actually--
or they get around this--
by modeling models and then
trying to, in the abstract,
figure out if those are
going to be good models.
So what you see is their
data processing pipeline.
The orange boxes use TensorFlow
probability extensively.
The orange bordered box is
where they use TensorFlow.
And the basic flow is to try
to treat the model itself
as a random variable,
and then determine
if it's going to be a
good model on otherwise
an incomplete data set.
And from this,
they're able to do--
they get remarkable
results, dramatic decreases
in false positives and false
negatives over very large data
sets in complicated systems.
So the question is, who will
be the next success story?
Try it out-- it's an open
source Python package
built using
TensorFlow that makes
it easy to combine deep learning
with probabilistic models.
You can PIP install it.
Check out
tensorflow.org/probability.
And if you're interested
in learning more
about Bayesian approaches,
check out this book,
which we rewrote using
TensorFlow probability,
within which you can learn,
like I said, Bayesian methods,
but also just how to use
TensorFlow probability.
If you're not a Bayesian,
that's fine too.
We have numerous tools
for frequentists.
We have a second
order generalized
linear model solver, which--
you should care, because if
you're doing linear regression,
it could solve that problem
on the order of 30 iterations,
which definitely cannot be said
of a standard gradient descent.
And if you want to find out
more about this example,
you can check out our
GitHub repository,
where you'll find several
Jupyter notebooks.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]